What are you doing here?
Get out! This is my house!
You speak English?
Do you want to ruin me?
Go! Go, or I will call the police!
We - We no enemies!
You are English, aren't you?
You can only make trouble for me!
Please, Signore... you must help us...
What do you take me for?
I have to protect myself.
We... yesterday... railroad...
We thought... goodbye, Italy,
but then...
We - We very hungry.
My wife! She must not know
you are here.
I'll bring food. Then you must go.
Understand?
What are you carting today?
Wheat, why?
Hey! Are you asleep? Stop!
Why? You know me.
Good morning, Alfredo!
Don't be foolish, children,
let me through.
I am traveling for the State
and I am late already.
Shut up and pay attention!
What have you to declare?
Sugar... eggs... macaroni... rice...
...coffe... tea... and roast chickens.
The whole black market...
legal and illegal!
Inspect each bag!
Hands off my sacks!
Read this... if you can read.
What does it say there?
State Mills, it says.
Would you have the courage to touch
Government property?
You dare suspect that the bags
contain contraband?
My poor friend!
Suppose I should report you...
...and accuse you of mistrusting
a Government official.
You would get at least
five years hard labor!
But I am too good-natured...
Why didn't you speak up before?
Did I or didn't I say
that I was working for the State?
All right, let him go.
What did you think I had in my cart?
Englishmen, perhaps?
If you want to see Englishmen...
go to Calabria!
There you will find
as many as you wish!
Run for it.
Don't be afraid.
Are you English?
Yes... and it is too bad
I don't talk much Italian.
I learned only a few words at camp.
"How are you?" "It is warm today."
"Cigarettes." "To eat, to eat."
And... "pretty girl".
You speak Italian very well.
There, other shore... Switzerland?
Oh, no, much further.
And it is dangerous.
Something always happens.
You understand?
Dangerous... many soldiers.
We will go only at night.
They have many boats...
they patrol about 10 o'clock.
Calabria is too far away...
there is only Switzerland.
Switzerland... that is a lucky country.
War is so horrible... But my father
hopes for peace soon.
Someday I want to come back
to Italy.
Hey, Johnny! Come back! Come back!
Ar... mis... tice!
Isn't this risky?
Oh, no! Allied prisoners
are in town celebrating.
They are crazy with joy!
The War has ended!
What happened?
Wait here.
Uncle! Come down quickly!
Englishmen? You crazy?
The Germans are here!
You have to help them!
Easy...
first they need civilian clothes.
Have you some old suits for them?
You two wait here.
Don't try to cross the lake!
You must reach Switzerland
through the mountains.
Get to the railroad!
With luck, you may find
a freight car to hide in.
Let me through!
Let me go with my husband!
No, no, don't! What you are doing
won't help us any.
We are escaped prisoners.
English?
I am. He is American.
Where do you want to go?
Switzerland.
Let them go... they are all right.
Is the frontier open?
Yes, hurry. The Germans may patrol here
any moment.
Be careful in town.
You may endanger our people.
Can I help you?
We are looking...
My friend... and I...
Perhaps you prefer to speak French?
You are English?
And my friend is American.
We didn't know where to go,
so we came here.
You did well.
But... we are not Catholics.
That doesn't matter.
They said we could reach Switzerland
this way. True?
But you are not the only ones
who want to get there.
Every day there are more fugitives.
There is nothing to fear.
In any case, you can't go
any further tonight.
It will do you good to rest...
you look exhausted.
We are very tired, but by tomorrow
we will be all right.
I shall do my best for you.
I have another guest...
an interesting one.
You have returned. What happened?
A terrible snow storm in the mountains
forced us back.
Where is Giuseppe?
At the Inn.
We are desperate!
For Heaven's sake, help us!
Go to the Inn... You're soaked.
I'll join you shortly.
I have an idea...
Come with me. I'll get you one
who knows the way.
We must cross the street very quickly.
I am afraid we are giving you
a lot of trouble.
Don't be afraid.
We're here to help each other.
One must not magnify one's fears.
Much would not have happened
if we had been less afraid.
I shall cross first.
Giuseppe! The Priest is here.
I understand how unpleasant
this waiting is.
I know those mountains.
People freeze to death there.
They don't realize the danger!
The Germans are getting closer,
Father!
At any moment they may arrive here!
You are not the only one
who is in danger.
But how much longer
must we wait here?
Giuseppe, can you start out
tomorrow?
Maybe, but I can't promise.
Now I am going back home
to see my mother.
When the weather improves
I'll come for these people.
There is somebody else
who wants to join you.
A young Englishman who came to me
with his friend.
This is Giuseppe.
You can speak in English.
He lived in America once.
Giuseppe will tell you everything
you need to know.
Must you take all with you?
We will leave behind what we can.
I collected these papers
for thirty years, Father.
These papers are more important
than my life.
DEVELOPMENT OF EUROPE'S
MINORITY PROBLEM SINCE 1815
Go to sleep... I will mend
your stockings when they dry.
After my prayers
may I have a Zwieback?
Wait... don't run barefoot
over the cold floor.
I will carry you piggyback.
They are staying here.
That would endanger the inn-keeper.
You will stay with me.
Meanwhile, I am going to get you
something to eat.
When you get to the church,
go upstairs.
You will find somebody there.
Go ahead... there is nothing to fear.
We were sent here...
Does the Priest happen to be here?
I have a letter for you.
I believe you can stay here.
Careful, Father... that puddle.
Bad weather... bad times.
Those people at the Inn...
Your "proteges"...
they haven't left yet, eh?
They are probably leaving tomorrow.
Oh, there is no rush. Right now
they are not in danger.
Two new ones arrived tonight,
didn't they?
Yes, a poor woman and her son.
A few days ago she lost her husband...
he was deported.
She was on their list, too,
but she was warned.
These stories make your blood boil.
They'll pay for their crimes
sooner or later.
Tell me, it is Giuseppe
who will guide them, isn't it?
Ah, Giuseppe knows his business.
You're kind to take
these poor people's fate to heart.
Thank Heaven
you have nothing to fear.
After all,
they are not military refugees.
You see, I have not forgotten you.
We leave tomorrow...
these two and myself. It's better.
Father... that man...
isn't he a suspicious character?
Not long ago he changed
his political opinions.
It's official. The coup at Gran Sasso
has succeeded.
Il Duce is free!
Badoglio's plan to give him
to the Allies failed.
The German paratroopers and the SS
made the attack.
No doubt the maneuver
was carefully planned.
The troops landed
without arousing suspicion.
Keep tuned to this station.
More details will follow.
What am I to do now?
Nothing! Absolutely nothing!
Don't mix in politics anymore!
You of all people say that?
Tell me, who made money for us?
Who gave us position?
While the Fascist party existed
we did well.
When it collapsed,
what happened to me?
Once I had power and influence.
Now nothing.
They all avoided me...
even the Priest!
I haven't forgotten his sermons.
All he did was denounce informers...
profiteers... bribers.
Those speeches were for my benefit.
But listen... things are different
again, I assure you.
Now it is their turn to lick my boots!
I am going to the valley.
And if anyone asks where I am,
you don't know.
Did you hear that, Father?
Yes, yes.
But where are they shooting from?
Not far from here.
Near the bridge, I think.
Not the bridge.
They can't be that close.
You are right!
That means they are coming here!
They are attacking the village!
You must leave immediately!
They are coming!
The whole village must be evacuated!
Our men can't hold them off
much longer!
Maria! Get the children,
and some clothing! Hurry!
Father, what about the children?
They will stay with me.
The old people stay too.
The rest hide in the woods.
What! No guide for the people!
Giuseppe isn't here!
Send them all to the church.
Quickly, please!
You have to leave, too, Father!
You can't stay here!
Be calm. Ring for Mass... it is time.
Remember those people you saw
at the Inn?
Well, they are outside.
They must get to Giuseppe,
the guide.
I beg you, Gentlemen,
take them with you.
Impossible. We can't take them.
They will never find their way
all alone.
It's not far to Giuseppe's village...
then you're free.
After all, they are fugitives, too.
Alright, we will take them.
God bless you!
These men will take you to the guide.
Go that way and continue
beyond the wood!
You will find a few houses...
ask anyone for Giuseppe!
Father... they are waiting for you
outside.
I... I have to conduct you to them.
You mean... I am under arrest?
Why didn't you go, too?
I thought you had gone.
You know perfectly well
that I would have stayed on.
In these last years
I have seen many horrible things.
I knew that sooner or later
they'd spare nobody.
And now... my hour has come.
I swear on my own soul
I didn't want this!
Will you permit me to see
my little flock just once more?
It is deserted...
There is not a soul anywhere.
But the guide must be here.
Try to understand...
Where is the guide?
Where is Giuseppe?
My son...
Dead... dead.
They came at midnight
and ransacked the village.
They found only one shotgun!
For that, they murdered our men
and burned our homes.
Where did they go?
Toward the frontier?
No, no, no! They went that way
over the mountains!
How many were there?
Many... many... many.
Let me show you
what these beasts are capable of!
That guide was our only hope.
We will never make it now.
If we were alone,
I'd try finding our way.
But if you get lost in this weather,
you are finished.
We can't just talk!
We must keep going!
And those soldiers have a map.
Oh, those Englishmen!
They only think of themselves!
It is so, isn't it?
You heard them yourself.
What are we to them?
"A lot of jerks!"
I beg you,
take these children with you!
They have no homes! No parents!
At least,
in Switzerland they won't starve!
Such incredible stupidity
lugging those papers!
Surviving is more important!
The devil with your suitcase!
Are you mad? My manuscript!
Oh, I will take it...
it is too heavy for you.
I can't go on... I can't.
I have to rest a little.
You go on and look after the child.
Don't sit down.
Oh, Lord! Cast us not off
in our old age!
Forsake us not
when our strength faileth.
Where is your Uncle?
I don't know!
Bernard, don't be childish.
Whenever we thought we were safe,
they appeared.
But... we are used to walking.
One emigration more or less
doesn't matter to us.
But the child,
at least should have a little peace.
Oh, God! If the Swiss only let us in!
Don't worry... they will let you in
with the child.
They are a friendly people...
they are like us Dutch.
Losing your illusions
about the close ones was awful.
Neighbors, friends...
even relatives betrayed you.
I bet there is wood for a fire
in that hut.
No stopping. We must close
the border gap by five.
If only we hadn't made
this wretched stop...!
Now we are finished!
For this we have gone through
so much.
For ten years we kept moving
just to die here!
This is nothing to these soldiers.
Let's trust them.
What more do you want.
We put them in danger.
What is wrong with you?
Nothing, Mother.
You look strange, come, sit down.
What are you thinking about?
I have - I mean, they have a plan.
Everything is going to be all right.
Come, lie down...
you look awfully tired.
Why are we stopping?
The frontier can't be far.
Where is my Bernard? Where is he?
Up there, with the others.
Bernard! He has gone mad.
Halt! Switzerland!
These people must have food.
We can stay here Lieutenant,
can't we?
For now, yes. I am powerless later.
Only children and those over 65
can enter the country.
They must return or prove
they're political refugees.
But we can't be sent back!
Don't worry now.
I'm in touch with the authorities
and I'll do my best.
The boy must undergo surgery.
Have you a truck here?
Get the lorry.
Get me Berne again.
The lorry is here, Sir.
Berne is on the wire, Sir!
Yes... speaking.
Is the Chief still busy?
I can't wait that long.
This is an emergency.
The people must go
into the valley at once.
Give me the authority to do
as I see fit.
What? You give me full authority?
Good.
We will do what we can, but...
Is he asleep?
Yes, he is asleep.
And Uncle Hillel,
will they let him sleep, too?
Yes, Hannele...
no one will disturb him anymore.
And Bernard?
Bernard is sleeping too...
deeply and soundly.
Where are we going now?
I don't know, Hannele.
There's nothing to fear now.
We don't have to hide any longer.
Poor boy... he is all alone now.
And for us... life begins again.
For myself, I know I must not give up
my work.
It is true. All is lost except
these sheets of paper.
But I now can say
what I intended to say.
No, Madame Monnier,
I shall not give up.
I shall begin again...
We are all going to begin again.